[Music]
thank you
to begin let me hold up this week's
spectator again migration nation is the
cover piece and it's about the news that
the government is expected to soon
announce or even admit that legal
migration net legal migration is
somewhere around 700 000 immigrants
coming into this country
it's a lot higher than was expected and
Fraser Nelson explores the possibility
that it may be being used to cover up
the large number of British people who
are on benefits he joins me now to
explain his thesis along with the
politician turned broadcaster Nigel
farage
Fraser I think what people find most
striking about your piece is uh that
brexit seems to have meant more
immigration not less because that was
not what we were told it would do now
during the campaign both the leave and
remain campaigns argue that brexit would
mean significantly less immigration you
couldn't find any economic analysis of
brexit but didn't assume that my net
migration would go down quite
significantly now you want some people
on the relief campaign were saying you
know what this is what we need fewer
migration and therefore scarce workers
have become more scarce therefore the
salaries go up and on the remain sides
there was a moment where Stewart Rose
the former m s Chief was in question
time and he rather famously said yes and
there'll be fewer migration that means
more content for Laborers and labor
costs will go up and that's not a good
thing so you had the two sides agreeing
on whether it was disagreeing on whether
it was good or bad the end that you
would end up with less migration and
perhaps higher salaries who have a low
paid and you can argue yeah people will
be paying more money for the Pizza the
waiters are paid more you know that kind
of argument but nobody disagreed that
brexit with significantly lower
migration and it would be a better way
of managing globalization that they
basically it got a bit out of control
under the Blair period in many ways
almost the whole point of leaving the EU
was to Take Back Control of Border
policy so we would exit the system of
free movement and being able to decide
how many we'd want what we now find is
when they've taken back control the
government's giving almost 500 000 visas
a year and when you include the students
who nowadays apparently have got one and
two dependents and two the number Hits
700 000 or probably more we're going to
get that next week but this isn't an
accident because Richie sunnank has now
got complete control you can decide
whether to issue a Visa or not so this
is deliberate policy but one that hasn't
been announced and one that hasn't been
explained and I think it should be well
we should say that by spectator office
standards you are something of a dove or
on immigration you'll certainly a dove
compared to the man sitting on your left
but you still find this very troubling
because because of unemployment because
of long-term sickness because of the
fact that a lot of British natives are
in a welfare trap essentially yeah I
think the mass immigration has been
overall quite a stunning success for
Britain and we have had a massive and
demographic change one in five of our
workers now is Fordham born and I think
in London um half of all children have
got an immigrant mother including I
should say my own three kids I'm
contributing to this phenomenon
um and I think that we've Managed IT in
an incredibly successful way if you look
at the coronation for example a couple
of weeks ago we had a Hindu prime
minister Buddhist Home Secretary Muslim
mayor of London Muslim first minister of
Scotland in no other country in the
world would you have had this picture of
successful integration so we pulled it
off very very well and I think we
continue to pull it off well we're
finding out Aviva status positions that
were getting three quarters of a million
net migration that hasn't been riots in
the streets about it there was no
populist party I mean while good Nigel
was running the brexit party talking
immigration they were used to becoming
first in the European elections only a
few years ago now there is nothing
nothing to the right of the
conservatives Richard Tyson's lot fueled
500 candidates of the locals they've got
something like five or six candidates
through a dreadful success rate so we
don't have any what you might call
anti-immigrant populist party or
anything approaching my description
either in Parliament or in the opinion
polls so the public seemed to be quite
happy with this if there isn't happiness
it hasn't expressed itself politically
now where I'm concerned is I think
although immigration works very well it
can perhaps work too well for Temptation
politically to use this to cover up the
failures of the welfare state is very
great like earlier on this week we had
figures coming out showing 5.3 million
Brits or now to work benefits we would
really notice that if it wasn't for Mass
immigration because we wouldn't have
anybody to run the economy but when we
can cover it up with mass migration it
works
Nigel you made some waves this week by
saying that brexit has failed
because of what the government's done
with it yes you know number one we
haven't actually helped business
businesses are leaving we've got a brain
drain going on for the first time since
the 1970s secondly there's an absolute
breach of trust with the electorate over
immigration which is absolutely
perfectly clear the only reason we won
that referendum were people turning out
on Council Estates in the Midlands of
the north thinking you know what this is
the one time my vote can make a
difference and thirdly uh brexit is
failing because it's actually turned out
that our politicians are about as
useless as the European commission now
you know that doesn't mean voting to get
back sovereignty was wrong far from it
but in the minds of ordinary brexit
voters this isn't working and I'd remind
Fraser there were a third group of
people in that referendum uh talking
about immigration those that didn't want
to talk about it at all I remember being
told you know by Hanan and Boris Johnson
no no no no no don't discuss immigration
in the referendum we'll lose the
referendum you know some of our very
Posh friends don't like this sort of
thing in the end they were forced to
talk about it reluctantly but they never
ever Boris never intended to reduce the
numbers of people coming into this
country so the First Fundamental
question to address is that breach of
faith I think it's very strong and very
real and secondly let me say this
the electorate assumed with brexit that
immigration had been dealt with
and they're now beginning to understand
that it hasn't been dealt with
and you may well say there's no populist
party in British politics at the moment
there will be it's coming disconnect the
disconnect is bigger now than it was in
2010. I could see in 2010 that the
political media class in London just had
no idea what everybody else in the
country was talking about and I think
we're heading back to that and quite
quickly let's get on to the future of
properties politics in a moment because
I think that's where they should go and
for now it's fair to say polls suggests
that immigration has dipped in in terms
of the issue which voters consider most
important I think it's now fourth or is
it Fifth what if it's not being
discussed that's not surprising I mean
if there is no coverage of the issue and
people don't know what's going on that's
not surprising the reason the reason
that immigration became the big
political issue that it was
is that people in their minds linked it
to membership of the European Union that
was what the ukip surge was all about
that's what you successfully did yes and
it took me years yeah it took me years
to make that connection and I from 2004
I said to all the people working with me
once I can make this connection this
political part is going to a different
place
I think over the course of the next year
or two people will start to make the
connection that the reason there's a
housing crisis is mass immigration the
reason they can't get a GP appointment
is mass immigration the reason their
lives are more miserable than they were
10 years ago their quality of life is
diminishing is because of the population
crisis an explosion in this country but
in what way is it a crisis you're living
in London earning good money living in a
lovely house talking about rich Hindus
who happen to be our prime minister go
out onto the council Estates meet people
I think you'll see the audience you know
my driver my driver my driver's kid
didn't go to school last year the
school's too full 13 years old not at
school right so your driver what you're
saying that the local authorities
refused to provide this child with the
police because they're in education
places that's right it's happening all
over the country doesn't this illegal
for your councils to refuse people no
home education has been given online no
place at schools you go to Lincolnshire
for example you'll find four and a half
five-year-olds maybe 20 miles on a bus
to get to school you there is a
population explosion that is damaging
and diminishing the quality of life of
ordinary folk in this country if you
don't see it now I promise you you will
see but why is it well I can't work out
is this if there is this um this anger
then why hasn't got no political
expression why does um why the reform
party do something incredibly badly just
a few weeks ago if we polled a thousand
people in Stoke on Trent now and asked
who the Reform Party was I wonder how
many would know that it even exists you
know that's the problem you know we may
know because we live in this world
ordinary folk don't know and actually
establishing political movements is not
an easy thing to do and reform is
effectively you know it may be a
follow-on from the brexit party but
effectively it's a new political party
so two things I would say number one the
reason we're not seeing this expressed
more is because it's not been given
voice but it's beginning to be we're
having this National debate now about
numbers and number two there's not a
political leader that people can see at
this moment in time voicing their
concerns once those connections are made
between I mean everything even travel
even travel even even the length of
Journeys potholes in the roads these are
all symptoms of a population crisis and
it's going to dominate British politics
over the next 10 years is it not a
problem then if as you say for because
of brexit well brexit came about because
people linked the European Union of mass
migration now people will say well we've
had brexit and we still have mass
migration no we don't know what they'll
say is they lied to us yeah they lied to
us but maybe they wanted control over
immigration that's the big difference
United that before there was probably no
control
um free movement that's what it means
right you cannot draw it now right now
if you look at this coming in there are
different people but not the pools the
Indians are now number one Follow The
Thing by Australians then you have
Nigerians then you have Americans now to
get a visa for this country you need to
be over a certain salary threshold you
need to speak English you need to be
getting a job in a certain profession
this was
wait a second I got a second
I mean the salary criteria
when Australia does this it says we're
short of Engineers we're short of people
in these sectors we will open up spaces
in this sector in nearly every single
case those that go to Australia are
earning more than the average wage what
this government have done is they've
lowered the thresholds the most
unimaginable levels where actually the
threshold to come in is eight to ten
thousand pounds lower than the average
wage that's why the numbers are where
they are they have deliberately
engineered this and of course they've
got their big business friends
encouraging it but equally as you point
out in your article there is this
massive welfare is a problem of 5.3
million people and it appears at the
minute that no political party's got the
courage to take that on so it's all well
and good to say you have to pass these
tests to come in but we've set the
threshold so low in terms of
qualifications and income as if as for
it to almost be meaningless maybe this
is making it more palatable though maybe
that is why when there's a recent poll
asking people all over the world what do
you think of immigration Britain emerged
as the most Pro country in the world
other than I think Norway and I wonder
if that's because we see the migration
differently now now the brexit has come
along we know that to get a Visa you
need a job nobody's really talking about
lazy foreigners who aren't really you
know these are people who are by and
large more likely to work and then Brits
now nobody was ever talking about lazy
foreigners that was never the argument
the argument was about wage compression
the argument was about difficulties
getting onto social housing lists the
argument was about fundamental changes
in community the argument was about the
fact well why is never speaking English
a mystery they were very very different
arguments and they were arguments very
firmly rooted around Community around
family and of course the ironic social
conservatism of so many labor voters you
know which actually is still there I
mean you know those red wall voters are
surprisingly small C conservative and
patriotic people in many many ways so no
I think that the idea that well we've
got back control we've chosen not to use
it but we've got control so we're all
happy is I think it's for the birds
friends
I mean you've focused a lot on illegal
migration in your in Immigration yeah in
your journalism and so on yes uh do you
think the fact that that is such a media
uh preoccupation distracts from the the
issue of legal migration which as you
say is the reason I did that the reason
I went on this illegal immigration thing
back in sort of late 19 early 20s is
because nobody else wanted to talk about
it was literally being buried under the
carpet so I thought well I'm gonna you
know cause a bit of noise on this and
get because it was obvious to me in 2020
that the numbers that came would explode
because virtually nobody was being
deported anywhere else and you can come
in be put in a hotel you still and you
literally stay in a four-star hotel and
go to work every day in the black
economy and earn cash it's happening all
over the country so I pushed that
because I wanted it I wanted it to
become a big issue also because you know
my fear from 2015. and the reason that I
use that Breaking Point poster that's so
upset the Metropolitan Elite is that the
EU have made the same mistake with the
Mediterranean
um and I feared
I feared that unless we got a grip
through brexit that we'd face a similar
wave now it may not be the same
numerically but symbolically the boat's
crossing the English channelism but the
way the numbers that are crossed into
Europe so far across the Met is trouble
last year so there's more of this coming
but ironically yes everyone's now become
so focused on what's been happening
illegally with 45 46 000 people last
year that you're right it's it's it's
it's kind of stopped us talking yes
about legal net numbers I remember you
accepted an award at The Spectators
parliamentarian of the Year Awards a few
years ago and you said you'll never hear
from me again okay
well I have to ask you do you think
there's obviously a space opening up to
the right of Richard now particularly on
the issue of immigration will you be
going back I think it's I think it's
bigger than that I think the absolute
betrayal of the five and a half million
men and women who were sole Traders and
self-employed I mean you can't believe
the anger in that Community out there
they load the conservative party they
fear labor will be even worse but they
load the conservative party the complete
lack of understanding of how the ir35
rules in practice are working in the
building industry Etc so it isn't just
on immigration there is a I think the
sense of detachment
the the conversations that are happening
in Westminster are so far removed from
older people's lives I mean what I
campaign with the brexit party in 2019
quite successfully we got rid of Mrs May
and I'm rather proud of that but the
slogan we campaigned on wasn't even
about brexit it was change politics for
good there was a hope and a feeling that
a different kind a more engaged kind of
politics would come from brexit none of
that's happened so they asked you a
question is very simple
the Gap that is opening up
in British Politics on the center right
um is potentially bigger than it was
with UK yeah I mean I mean it's a very
very big gap you very skillfully didn't
listen to the second part about my
question which is will you try and fill
that game I haven't finished yet sorry
give me a moment I was ignoring you I
can be accused of many things ignoring
questions so the potential is there and
something or someone at some point is
going to fill it you know I I sort of
call it an anger Gap
now it depends who fills that anger Gap
I hope and believe what I did before was
a positive way of filling it by saying
let's get our sovereignty back as a
means of dealing with these problems
before I came along the already came to
prominence the anger Gap was being
filled by Nick Griffin and it's very
easy to forget between 2005 and 2010 the
extent to which the BMP were laying down
Roots you know in those Northern Town
councils Etc
I I haven't decided what I'm going to do
I mean I'll be honest with you
um
I I do feel
that a large chunk of the country
deserves some representation and
deserves a voice
equally
um I still pretty bruised by the 2015
general election how can you get four
million votes in one seat it makes it a
very difficult thing to do
I haven't decided what I'm going to do
but something's going to come along if
it's not me it'll be it'll be a Nick
Griffin Mark too you know we will we
will have a rise of something way out on
the right it's happening as we speak all
over Europe albeit aided by
propulsion representation system
something is going to change something
is going to crack and I think
coming back to UK politics uh you know I
think I've got a better understanding of
those red wall voters than than pretty
much anybody frankly
um they were the people that were the
backbone that built ukip up into being a
major party in British politics
and if the conservative party on its
current course thinks he's got any
chance of winning a single one of those
seats that that I'm afraid they're
deluded the only thing that might save
us is this the one thing the
conservative party is really good at is
survival you know it's been around for a
couple of hundred years it exists to
attempt to get power and to hold power
so they've still got time I guess if
they chose to be genuinely radical but I
can't see it happen by radical you mean
cutting a number of visas issued versus
your definition because the funny thing
is we've just had local elections and
how many parties are various Stripes
Just For Speed is not a sign not a sniff
of the sort of anger that you're talking
about because
is it real or might it be because
there's no way but but that was like
that that was the same effectively
before 2010 you know other than the BMP
you were just selling it I think Griffin
was getting a huge number palpable anger
then the BMP in the north but they had a
big presence
at the moment if you want to vote that
way there's nobody giving a voice to it
that's the Gap in the market but it
looks like a lot of those verses are
going back to labor now yes I've met
them this weekend yeah I've met them
this week why do you think they're going
back to it is it because Kirsten was
talking to the right on some things no I
just I think this Tory party they don't
identify with these conservative
politicians at all they briefly did with
Boris for a bit he seemed rather fun uh
he seemed rather normal identify with
cure storm right no not really so why
are they going back to labor because
they're tribal labor that's where they
come from they've been their families
have voted labor since 1918. you know
the the sort of the gateway drug
of ukip and the brexit party took them
to the conservatives in 2019 and that
was on a brexit let's get this thing
sorted out let's get back control of our
borders
um but they're going back to labor
because that's where they're from
and the concern and and I think there's
also a profound sense of disappointment
that the brexit thing has not worked out
the way they really wanted it to
I think we'll wrap it up there but uh
thank you very much thank you for coming
in and thank you very much for talking
about your cover piece
thank you
[Music]